this man's credits includes madmen
billions Goliath and now Watchmen every
single Sunday night at 9 p.m. Eastern on
HBO he is James Wolcott to see you sir
it's serious he's got it you're from
this great state of Michigan huh I am
where we're in Michigan I was born and
raised in Farmington Hills Michigan
arming tinel's Michigan yeah okay about
45 minutes or so and you went to the
University of for four years for four
years so so you grew up a Michigan fan
or are you state what are you because
it's very important you declare right
now yes this week as you know this
weekend is a pretty huge one committee
game yes it is big game I'm definitely a
Michigan fan all my cousin's my mom side
went to Michigan State and then my
cousins on my dad's side went to
Michigan so your cousins on your
mother's side yes all right uh with all
due respect they're not as smart tell my
uncle all the time now I'm just very
bright Thanksgiving around the corner
James Christmas yeah serious though this
is serious business
it's like this weekend and I'm sure
again fans out there of Alabama and
Auburn and Oklahoma Oklahoma State yeah
obviously Clemson South Carolina that
there there's there are houses divided
in state rivalries all over our great
country yeah this is this is one of the
top ones here this is big Michigan
Michigan State's huge I remember when I
went there as a freshman yes uncle came
this great guy Uncle Bill and he came to
take me to lunch and I sat down with him
a very cocky confident eighteen year old
and I said Uncle Bill we are gonna win
four years in a row against Michigan
State okay and if we do you owe me
dinner and vice versa and we won somehow
we won every year I was there is that
right yeah I mean no he just send you
back yeah although you finished up the
Lloyd Carr years right yeah Lloyd yeah
so were you at the Appalachian State
game no that was after you graduate
after I graduate see we got to send you
back James I'm honestly that was really
clearly we found we found
a lucky horseshoe here yeah that was
rough
well I changed everything mm-hmm that
changed everything because that soured
so many people in in the alumni base on
Lloyd even though you know he is a
legend yeah and things just went
downhill and then eventually he did get
you know replaced right there's one one
way to put it
that's right but going out the door he
beat Urban Meyer and Florida with Chad
Henne going five while he went he's out
of a three-yard cloud of dust they went
five wide and beat Irvin and Tim Tebow
look it up that's how Lloyd Carr went
out the door he was a great coach again
he was a great coach I know yeah so okay
what did you did you take up acting on
the campus in Ann Arbor did you do that
son yeah I came into the University of
Michigan and I was in the the School of
Music there so I got a bachelor in Fine
Arts in theater okay and studied English
and you know that's the great thing
about Michigan is that it's just such a
great I could just talk about Michigan
it's just so it was great because you
can take if you're a BFA you could take
like sciences and English in art so I
got a really nice well-rounded education
but I studied acting another in college
okay and yeah I did uh I work for the
student newspaper the Michigan daily
Michigan daily did you work for it - I
didn't but I read it okay for a great
great pay yeah my column was called get
rich quick nice that's what it was that
because that was my snappy that's how I
got my Awards Chris way back in the day
Chad Henne had 373 yards in that yeah
right and they beat Tebow and urban head
in the Orange Bowl right correct
I know a citrus ball citrus I knew it
was some sort of uh some sort of 4135
Wow as they went out the door rich rod
was standing on the sidelines for to
rank nine now you see yeah hmm god I
loved Lloyd Carr he's a good man and his
whole family is - with the Chad tuff
foundation and in Ann Arbor people
should look it up give all your if you
want to donate money to a great cause
for pediatric health that is the one for
you to also check out James walk here on
the Rich Eisen show okay so now let's
talk about your career what was the what
was you what would you call your biggest
break in your career
James well the first thing I ever did
where I was able to do some real acting
was it was about a year after college
and I went in for a film it's a true
story about a guy who had - Rhett
syndrome called front of the class and I
ended up playing this guy's name was
Brad Cohen
out of Atlanta Georgia and that kind of
was my entry into into the business okay
that's the big jump as you go from being
on a stage in college to graduating he's
going like how do I get paid for this
right or get anyone to pay attention and
that was the thing that I knew I could
you know make a living doing it right
exactly and then so um then Mad Men
billions Goliath I mean you you have
worked on some great television shows
now Watchmen I do want to kind of jump
around a little bit here yeah what is it
like being on something with a rabid fan
base that is no doubt combing through
every detail of your show to make sure
you are being faithful to what they
believe needs to be hewed to completely
what is it like for you yeah yeah
because Watchmen is obviously based on
the graphic novel Watchmen you know the
the thing that takes the pressure off
for us quite frankly is that Damon
Lindelof the creator basically said look
this isn't washed in the graphic novel
this is Watchmen and it's set 20 years
30 years after what took place in the
graphic novel so it's kind of to use his
words a remix on it so we don't feel
like we're exactly creating these
characters in the exact age that they
appeared in the graphic novel with all
the chronology of those events it's set
in present-day kind of a dystopian
United States with the president being
the president being Robert Redford
Richard Nixon was the president for 30
years and then and then Redford got him
out of office and now Redford is the
president in our show president Robert
Redford President Robert ladies and
gentlemen okay yep a river runs through
it so I think that takes the pressure
off is that you go like alright well you
know let's let's just roll with it you
try and just bring as much honesty and
integrity as you can to the scripts that
Damon and his team are writing right and
the good news is I think the the fan
response has been pretty solid I think
they well I mean yes
the ratings have been obviously through
the roof yeah one metric in which to
measure whether fans are digging it
rather or not but we also don't know
your character you play a Republican
senator named Joe Keene jr. from
Oklahoma where this is taking place yep
we don't know if you're a good guy or a
bad guy just yet and I'm wondering uh
what Keene yeah whether you could tell
us so Senator Kean and to talk about the
graphic novel sure Keene is the son of
this guy named senator Keene who
appeared in David Gibbons
you know Watchmen the original one that
came out yes years ago and he outlawed
vigilantism which is the whole thing
behind the the graphic novel is that
superheroes can't be superheroes anymore
and they're kind of in hiding and trying
to do it illegally and so I am his son
and you know when we meet Senator Joe
Keene Joseph King jr. in the show you
know he's incredibly ambitious and
political and he comes into the fold and
you meet him and you just know him as
this this senator who kind of has you
know daddy issues he's trying to surpass
where his father was as a senator his
presidential ambitions and it was really
fun to play this character because he
didn't exist in the graphic novel right
so I got to go like all right well
here's my version of this person that no
one knows and no one could say well it's
not you know true to the graphic novel
so there's a lot of creative license for
me in the carriage I need what can you
tell fans about what the hell's
happening in this show right now so in
the show right now if you've been
watching I think the fifth episode is
gonna air this Sunday 9:00 Eastern 9:00
Eastern HBO there is a death that takes
place in in Tulsa Oklahoma and much like
the graphic novel that started with the
death and the mystery that surrounds it
our show starts in a very similar way
and you go on this journey with Regina
Kings character trying to figure out why
this person was killed who did it and
and what was their motivations and
everyone in the show was trying to
figure that out and it's incredibly
important to my character Senator Kean
because he's very close with the man who
was killed to find out why this happened
and it's just a wild ride man and one
thing I would suggest actually yes
as my parents are watching it and they
go like I really like it you know but
I'm a little confused on this thing so I
sent them an article okay I think it was
Entertainment Weekly and it said the
five things that you should know about
the graphic novel to fully you know wrap
your mind around the show you don't need
to know them right I think it would it
would just give you a little bit of a
background if you're gonna check it out
did your parents ever watch Lost
did they ever watch that show you know
what my parents didn't watch loss but I
did you did yeah so you could basically
say look there's something called a
smoke monster this guy once created I
don't know where the hell this guy's
going right he's the master of keeping
you guessing Damon I know unbelievable I
know and you don't know sometimes when
what what's real what's not or what you
know what what is really happening and
yep
it's really great Watchmen Sunday nights
9:00 Eastern Time on HBO and again you
this is a hell of a cast
I mean who have you been on a show with
I mean you been on a show with a ton of
people man yeah you're like that the kid
in Ann Arbor would be like come on I'm
on a show with this person I mean what
do you got for me on that yeah I've had
some mind-blowing experiences and
especially right out of college
formative years - I worked opposite you
know Jon Voight in a show I did back in
2010 which was just basically two years
after graduation right I remember we
were working together and someone said
we should go and watch is it homecoming
it's homecoming coming home coming home
excuse me yes coming home just watch
coming home and I watched coming home in
in the middle of filming the pilot
episode with him and I shouldn't have
done that
because I was so nervous to act opposite
him after I watched that because he was
so pure yeah so real and that I think he
won the Academy Award yeah they could
have told you Midnight Cowboy - yeah and
he's unbelievable and I had that
experience I worked with Robin in his TV
show kind of return after Mork and Mindy
we did a show called the crazy ones
together with Robin Williams yeah and I
got to improv with him come on you know
pinch yourself moment every day for a
year I got to improv with him so it was
amazing did you ever pass out yeah I
mean I could not imagine like I mean
obviously doing scripted with him
something like that but actually like
okay it's now your job
stole cloth it with Robin Williams yeah
it was incredible like I still I still
have those moments all the time
of just you know going like why I can't
believe I'm getting the joy and pleasure
of working opposite this person I grew
up loving right watching and Robin is a
perfect example of that right I mean in
this cast too
again I don't want you to give anything
away but people who are in it Louis
Gossett jr. Lou Gossett jr. Jeremy Irons
okay
you know everyone is just really it's
it's an it's an incredible cast and
Regina
I mean Regina is so good in the show
she's she's an amazing actress but she
gets to be front and center right I mean
she carries this thing she carries it
beautifully and she has such grace and
strength and she's really a Titan well
you're an actor of who's been in a ton
of great stuff again we're here with
James woke on the Rich Eisen show and I
don't expect you to know Jeremy Irons
filmography off the top of your head but
if you had to name give me like two or
three great Jeremy Irons roles what
would you name James oh my god I just
you know I here I'll just I'll describe
the movie to you because the names
escape me cuz I just watched it where he
plays the wealthy husband of the woman
who gets killed
Klaus when he played Klaus von Bulow
that is in his in his his world famous
role what's the name of that film in now
now see now it's popped out of my head
Hospital that's right right and he won
the Academy Award right that that's
that's that's one he's out of there but
everything from that to the man in the
iron mask man in the iron mask film but
he's good at every reversal of fortune
and man in the iron mask those are two
versatile for course of course and would
you name go ahead Chris
diehard three would I name that is one
of his yes why not everything he does is
good read a phone book you'd go wow
that's finally good reason why I bring
this up okay is is about a year ago I
was the second guest on Seth Meyers Late
Show uh-huh late night okay
and Jeremy Irons was the first and we
went to New York because I was appearing
in New York to do it right this guy I'm
like guess who I'm on with
did not knew who the gate a guest was
until or during our show right mentioned
Jeremy Irons and he goes first reaction
you know live TV radio just pops out of
your head so the heat says that and then
sure enough sure enough I'm sitting in
the green room watching him get
introduced by Seth Meyers yeah he's been
in such great movies as reversal of
fortune and die hard with a vengeance
totally undercut my position right
question was there's so many others you
could date for that not that and it's
not even the best die hard by a long
stretch not even the top to die hards
yeah he's his voice the way his voice
its second alright I'll go there one
more time do you think diehard the
original is a Christmas movie yes I do
you got to know why I don't have a good
reason I'm taking loss after like an L
it's on during Christmas all right well
we're out of time James go watch tired
three James woke four more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app